I'm going to have some of the viewers play a drinking game of how many times Matthias says,
here's a tip during this episode.
People are going to be like wasted as heck after that.
So before we started this episode, I was like, all right, man, tell me how to pronounce your name.
Give it to me now because I'm not going to get it right.
You mean my handle?
Yeah.
And that means what?
It means like you want someone to call Del Novel and...
Dude, I don't know.
Why do we have the weirdest handles, man?
Mine is like some freaking like video game gun from when I was like 12.
And you're telling people to fall down a well.
Well, that's lovely, man.
But there's a little story to that.
It's like that was like something that a friend of mine or an ex-college of mine used to say as like an insult
because he's from up north and apparently they say it there.
And so I was signing up for some service.
I forget which one it was.
It might have been Gmail, but it could have been something else too.
It might have been Gmail.
Yeah, yeah.
But it's like, oh, that's taken.
Oh, that's taken.
So I just put that in and it's like, you know what?
This is never going to be taken anywhere.
I'm sticking to it.
Dude, that's freaking great, man.
And so you named yourself...
Yeah, in English, there's like, you know, go jump in a lake is what people...
Or jump off a cliff or something like that people will say.
That's hilarious that you put that as your name.
Well, dude, welcome to the pod with that lovely start.
Welcome to the pod.
And thanks for coming on.
It's, you know, one of the things that I love about podcasting is that you kind of get to catch up with people a little bit.
Like, I'm kind of bad at like keeping up with all my bug bounty friends.
And I haven't...
I mean, we haven't spoken in like...
Man, it's probably been almost five years.
Maybe four years.
So how have you been, man?
What have you been up to?
Why haven't you been at the live hacking events?
I don't know.
It's a long story.
I got kind of burnt out, I guess, around 2020 or around when Corona hit.
Yeah, yeah.
The live hacking events stopped.
Yeah.
And then I also had some other issues.
Like in my life, my relationship wasn't going anywhere and we broke up.
And then instead of handling it, I started playing World of Warcraft.
Classic.
Classic move right there.
Oh, man.
I found some interesting stuff in like the World of Warcraft.
Are you hacking World of Warcraft?
Yeah.
Well, they didn't let me do some stuff in like a add-on that I wanted to do.
Nice.
That's great, man.
Well, you know, I will say the burnout thing is something that's real, real, real.
You know, like pretty much everyone who's on the live hacking event circuit deals with it.
And especially if you're, you know, you're doing every event for a little while like you were.
It becomes a lot.
But you were actually, did you?
You came to Vegas this year and you guys won, right?
Yeah.
That's a good comeback.
Now, oh, dang it.
Move your head a little bit to the side.
Is that two?
Is that two belts I see up there?
Yeah.
Dang it, man.
I need a new film.
Freaking people, you know, for a little while it was me and Franz with the two belts.
And I was like, all right, you know, I can be happy with this.
And now the number has grown substantially.
And now I got to like get my shit together and get another belt.
So bummer, man.
Well, yeah, I would have loved to have been in Vegas this year and seen you.
But, you know, such is life.
And now we get to catch up here.
So that works well.
Yeah.
So I guess 2020, burnout a little bit.
Stopped doing bug bounty period for a while or what?
Yeah, basically.
The only thing I did 2021 and 2 was like helping some people who asked me questions.
So I got like a couple of collaboration reports.
Other than that, nothing.
Yeah, dude.
That was a underrated revenue stream for me as a podcaster.
Because what will happen is, you know, people will message me.
And let me just also put this out there for the people that are listening.
I will definitely help with bugs.
But they need to be actual bugs, you know?
They need to be actually good leads, right?
So people will message me sometime.
They'll be like, hey, I've got this, you know, XSS I can't quite figure out.
But clearly, you know, we're escaping the XSS context.
And there's a valid, you know, XSS here.
We just got to like get around this WAF or we've got to like, you know, code golf in some exploit.
And I love that.
And it's been a great, it's been, you know, people, I think on average, I've made like two or three K a month from like people reaching out to me since I've launched the podcast being like, hey, exploit this.
So it definitely does help when you're, you know, well known for your exploitation capabilities.
Yeah, I want to give a tip actually about collaboration.
Yeah.
And also what I've been doing this past week with some friends.
I think that another thing that's super underestimated is to try to become maybe expert is the wrong word, but really knowledgeable about a specific technology or like development stack or some area.
Yeah.
And then you can talk to people who specialize in like a couple of different programs and maybe they can just like search their verbs and like, yeah, they use a blah, blah, blah thing here.
You can get like paid for that research.
Across all of the programs too.
Yeah.
And this is something that, you know, we've had Nogli on the podcast a couple of times or, well, I guess we've had him at least once.
But there's more to come.
And, and he, you know, he does a great job with this is like, he's got an automation setup.
That's, you know, pretty much one of the best around.
And, you know, people will hit him up and be like, hey, I've got the zero day.
And he'll just, you know, help everyone exploit it across all the, all the programs and help everyone, you know, sort of tie up those loose ends and get it, get a cut of it.
So, you know, it's great on, on the, on the distributor side and it's also great on the researcher side too.
And definitely, yeah, that's a, that's a great tip and under underestimated way to make a good chunk in bug bounty, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
The, the, the, yeah, it's, and, and on top of that, you know, you get, if you're doing quality research, you know, you get access to the research as well.
You know, you, you're, you're doing quality research that you can release and it's good for, you know, publicity and that sort of thing.
But the catch there is you've got to find something that's widely used.
So it's, it's a little bit tricky because, you know, if you, if you go down this rabbit hole and you research something and then it's not widely used, you know, you'll be like, oh, I found this crazy bug.
And then there's like three companies that use it or something like that.
Yeah.
That's pretty funny.
I've had, I've had a lot of those too.
Like I, I found the, I found the.
Pre-auth RCE in a.
Open source project.
Oh my gosh.
That like a company put out, which had a bug boundary program.
Yeah.
But I couldn't find an instance that they were using it themselves.
What?
Yeah.
So it was probably just some internal system, or behind VPN or whatever, somewhere.
So I reported it to them and they were like, oh, we don't think this is such a big deal.
And I got like, not that much.
How do you think a pre-auth RCE is not a big deal?
Hey man, don't touch me.
But I put it, I put in like a signature in my automation there.
Uh, but I've only, I found a couple of them, but since it's patched now, like every time I see that pop up, I'm like damn.
And that sucks, man.
You know, when I took a double edged sword there.
It is.
And when I did the Grafana bug in, um, in 2020, I had a, um, pre-auth full read SSRF on Grafana that like popped me like 70 companies or something ridiculous like that.
It was like, and it was just always straight to the AWS metadata too.
Cause everyone always spins it up in AWS.
Right.
Um, and I was like, okay, you know, I've, I've kind of sprayed this around and then I finally released it.
And, and, um, you know, before I did, I really like, somebody told me like, Hey, I think it was Naffy.
I think Naffy hit me up and was like, Hey man, um, I'm pretty sure GitLab has like an embedded version of Grafana in it.
Right.
And I was like, oh my gosh, you know, and, and it was vulnerable to that too.
So you could like hit, hit up, uh, you know, any GitLab instance that was publicly facing was also vulnerable.
Um, so it's also, I think another good tip for that is like, if you can take, take a piece of software and see if other pieces of software are, um, are actually utilizing that as a part of their stack.
Uh, you know, even if it's full applications like Grafana being embedded inside of GitLab, then sometimes you can pop an additional set of, of phones there.
Yeah.
And it does like the even better points.
Or if you can manage to find it is defined like insecure defaults or ways of setting it up in an insecure way, because then it won't, it probably won't be even touched.
Yeah.
And so now you're sitting on something that will, will not like have an end of, end of life.
Yeah, dude.
Yeah.
Insecure defaults is, is huge, man.
That would be, yeah.
Looking into that and then spraying it, spraying it wide is, is a great idea.
Um, you mentioned a second ago, your automation setup and so I've got it, you know, here on our little, on our little, uh, doc, our very hard doc that all of a sudden became very, very long.
As I've stalked you over the past five years to, to consolidate all of the content that you've produced down into, uh, into one podcast.
Um, but so I know you have a little bit of a origin with asset note, right?
Um, you know, when asset note was just a baby, uh, you were kind of sort of involved in that.
So I'd like to hear about that.
And then I'd also like to hear about what your automation setup looks like nowadays.
Yeah.
So when it comes to asset note, and I guess the same is true for the tech file layer, like, yeah, I don't think that anything is left of my contributions.
Uh, like, yeah, like an actual product and everything.
Um, but back in the day, let's say what happened was that Chubbs made the first like jank version of, uh, asset note and put it open source.
And then that project kind of died and I was interested in building something similar.
So I found this project and I asked him just straight up, Hey, is there any like full requests that you didn't merge or like code that you didn't commit?
Can you, can you do it?
Because I'm going to do something with this.
Yeah.
Can I have any free code please?
I mean, like if there was bugs and you all have to fix them, can I?
Exactly.
No, this is great.
I love this question.
Yeah.
But then it was like really excited that someone took an interest to it, I suppose.
And we started building it together.
Um, until, uh, until I guess he, or we realized that it became an effective enough solution, I guess, that could actually be turned into a real valuable product.
Yeah.
Um, and, uh, so then we forked again and I, I chose to keep my version with just like, I rewrote almost all of it too.
So now it's like we converged and we did.
What?
Gotcha.
I know, I know, I know that he credits you a lot with, um, you know, some of the momentum that he had with, uh, with, uh, with Asino in the beginning.
I'm sure with that, um, you know, initial interest sort of reviving the project.
And then also like something about project men, uh, you know, he was on the episode, like, like there was some sort of like project management help they needed or something like that.
And then you guys helped them out with that.
I don't know what that was, but I, I, it's, it must feel great to be, uh, a part of such a big, you know, thing.
Cause like, I don't know, I don't know if you feel the same way, but I have like so much respect for the people at, at AssetNote, you know, what they built technically.
And also just to see shubs, you know, and, and the whole team really Sean as well.
And, and, and all them, you know, being in our hacker groups and then going and building like this massive, you know, uh, product that is used by so many companies nowadays and just kind of taking that entrepreneurial route.
So that's gotta be pretty cool.
Yeah, for sure.
It's awesome.
I love Shubs and those guys.
They're great people and hackers.
Yeah, for sure.
So your automation, you said you've mostly rewritten it.
Um, what language are you?
Are you using?
What kind of stuff are you doing now in there that you're excited about?
It's still Python and Postgres and, uh, yeah, no, it's just simple.
I, I, I like simple code.
So I like the less complex it is, the more beautiful it is.
And that goes for systems and code or networks or whatever.
That's like my point of view of anything technical.
Do you, it just, it's, it has not, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
And like, just kind of see if I can at least get my instance sort of spun up again and get some host monitoring in place and that sort of thing.
And then I go back and I look at the code and I'm like, this is so freaking complex.
And even, you know, even one of the guys in the golden actually in the CTPB discord, he was asking me, you know, hey, you know, how do we deal with wild cards, wild card subdomains and how do we filter out, you know, the stuff that's not a wild card inside the wild card definition, right?
And I gave him, I gave him like this whole piece of code, which works, you know, in my defense, it does work really well and it does filter out the wild cards quite well, but it's like, it was like 500, 600 lines of code just to filter out a wild card, you know?
And, and so, yeah, I think it's a struggle to keep your code that simple.
And if you can, it's like so beautiful and helpful for automation.
Yeah, no, for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
And then like another tip there, I mean, maybe like, maybe I'm not up to date with a recent game because people are building such advanced, awesome stuff.
But one thing that I think it might be underrated, and this is only based on that I found them and I have been surprised that like, why don't people do this?
It's just that if you're going to do headless browser stuff, like for screenshots, for example, anyway, then you might as well audit the network logs or the DNS logs.
Because I've seen a lot of places where people have, like maybe it's not on get slash and maybe it's on some other page, but they, they will make some kind of external resource request.
Whether it's an image or like a script or something else to a domain that's either has a takeover or that's just like, you can just buy the domain.
And there you go.
Go do this.
All of you.
Now, see, this is the problem that you're about to learn after this episode, because you say stuff on the pod, right?
And then, you know, people actually listen to it and then they go do stuff and now your secrets are gone too.
So I should have, I should have warned you, you know, before this episode, but I appreciate you dropping that awesome tip because I'm sure that will lead to many, many takeovers and many, many bones for lots of targets.
So that's a, that's a freaking great tip, man.
Yeah, I want, I want to give tips.
Like it's a, it's a good challenge to just put stuff out there.
I think France noted it too, but like, yeah, it's good to get, get your secrets out there because then you need to get new ones.
And that motivates you to do research again.
Yeah.
I'm glad you both have that, that mentality.
That's really beneficial for me.
Yeah.
But on that point though, there's, there's different ways to publish your research too, I guess.
Uh, cause I, I'm not very good at writing blog posts or maybe I'm good at it, but I don't do it.
Freaking Franz just like pumps them out, man.
Like what the heck?
Yeah.
No, he's a beast.
Like the same way the like writing reports.
Like, yeah, he, he could be like one of those people.
What are they called?
Like when you're in court and you have to fight really fast.
Yeah.
I don't know what those things are called.
It could be one of those.
If like this, uh, thing is going.
Is it a stenographer?
Yeah.
Stenographer.
That's it.
That's the word.
Yeah, dude.
But he, I mean, it's crazy.
And I was looking at in prep for the episode of him.
I was looking at like the history of research that he's kind of put out over the past, you know, forever.
And, um, and I missed, you know, I had like a full list of like eight or nine or 10.
I was like, man, this guy puts out so much research.
And then we get in the episode and he's like, oh yeah, I wrote about this in that blog and this blog and that blog that I didn't have in the list.
And I was like, you are just like a freaking, you know, writing machine.
So yeah, that's very impressive.
And let me tell you, Matias, man, podcasting is great.
Can I highly recommend podcasting if you don't like writing reports?
Because you can just get on the pod, you know, you don't have to do multiple takes or whatever, and you don't have to like refine your, your thing like you do on YouTube and you get to just sit down, chat, you know, be authentic with the people and, you know, you get that information out there.
So maybe we'll have to make you like a, like a reoccurring guest on the podcast or something.
Yeah, maybe, maybe.
That sounds great.
Another thing is like another benefit of sharing is that if you're not very good at storing your information, I mean, you have it in your brain, obviously.
Yeah.
But it's like you get an archive of your stuff.
You don't forget it.
Yeah, go back and if you can deal with listening to your own voice, right?
Like, I, I, I listened to the pod every single week, the critical thinking podcast every week, just for like quality assurance purposes, and just to like make sure it's hitting, you know, the standards, and that sort of thing that I want.
And, and in the beginning, it was like nails on a chalkboard, man, it was like making me want to, what is it, I've lead in Bruin, it was making me want to jump in a well, man.
And, and, and, and, and, yeah, but after, after, you know, a couple episodes, I kind of, that kind of wore off a little bit.
And now it's not as, not as terrible, unless I laugh, you know, and then I'm just like, what the heck is that laugh, Justin?
What are you, what are you, what are you doing?
But yeah, it does help.
And also when you talk about it, and you, and you teach it, you know, or you discuss it with somebody, it concretes it a little bit more in your head.
And we were talking about this, you know, before we, we, we started the recording, but we've all got that sort of technical context window of sorts, right?
So like you deep dive a specific piece of content, you know, of, of research, and then like, you're super excited about it.
You've got it all in your head.
And then if somebody asks you a question about that three months later, it's like, oh man, I swear I knew the answer to this question, you know?
So, but if you get out there and you talk about it, it sticks a little bit better.
Yeah.
I, I had that this just like yesterday or if it was two days ago, we could, okay.
So backstory, friends and I have teamed up a little bit with the Cishano and Jonathan Bowman.
Oh man.
Oh gosh.
That combination, man.
Holy crap.
Yeah.
We found good stuff.
We started like last Friday or something.
But anyway, we, we found something that looked like a DynamoDB injection.
Yeah.
And I, I was like, I should know this because this summer, so I'm helping out with running and building CTEF challenges for a Swedish CTF called MeLightSan CTF.
And I made like a DynamoDB CTEF challenge.
Oh, did you really?
So at the time I had like, at least to me, novel research and stuff to do with DynamoDB.
Right.
But now when it came up just a few months later, it was like, I have no idea what that was.
Yeah, dude, that's so discouraging.
And then you're like, you know, all right, I got to like go back in my notes.
And then you're like, ah, shit, I don't have any notes.
And then you're like, you're just trying to piece it all back together.
But the good thing is at least, you know, that, that I think, um, you, you do have, you know, those neural pathways sort of primed of sorts.
Right.
And, and it does become easier to reaccess those once you've, you've done it.
But it is disappointing when you, you feel like you should know something off right off the top of your head and it's not, and it's not there.
Um, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
All right.
Let me get back to this.
Um, let me get back to this, this doc here.
You mentioned something, you know, about, about collaboration a second ago, you know, when we were talking about collaboration and I think you did a great talk, um, about this.
Uh, and I'm trying to see if I can find the link to the YouTube.
Wow.
I, I took like, uh, like six screenshots of this YouTube video and then I didn't actually, uh, save the video to my, uh, to my doc here.
So we'll link it down in the description below, but you did a talk at, I believe it was an OWASP, um, conference a while back talking about, about collaboration and mentioning that, you know, you, this sort of, um, concept of bounty effectiveness and how collaboration sort of affects that.
Right.
You know, you increase the number of bugs found, you decrease the risk of duplicates.
You, you, uh, you know, D crease the time taken because of how, you know, you're getting sort of double time.
Right.
Um, and I love this concept, man, of like.
Creating.
And we were kind of talking about it last week on the pod with, with, uh, Joel and Sam, even though they were kind of shitting on my idea of like, you know, trying to minimize bug bounty down to like a function of.
How many attack vectors or reasonable attack vectors is what I should have said that you try on a target, you know, over time.
Um, but I, I just kind of wanted to brainstorm a little bit on this together.
Um, this concept of like, how can we formula, uh, form you formula eyes turn into a formula, uh, that, you know, bug bounty.
Right.
And so I, I've got this concept around like taking optimizing for time spent actually trying reasonable attack vectors.
Um, and then you've got this concept of like calculating bugs found times risk of duplicate slash time taken, or, you know, divided by time taken results in your effectiveness.
Um, have you had any sort of evolution in this formula or evolution in your bug bounty optimization journey over the past, you know, I think it was five years ago that you did this talk.
Uh, I'm not sure.
Like on a high level, I think that's still true.
Because the end goal, at least for me with bug bounty is, is the same.
The only things that have changed is that, uh, there's been some additional factors added, I guess, to the time taken.
So for example, I'm going to take HackerOne for example, um, but I'm sure the other platforms do too.
Like they try to encourage you to use like the CVS as a system that takes more of your time and more programs are using, uh, like drive services.
Which unfortunately sometimes, uh, takes more of your time.
Yeah.
So those are like two sub parts of time taken that you can try to optimize too.
Yeah. Yeah. Trying to, trying to identify programs that will triage efficiently and are capable with their own products, I think is, is definitely a big thing.
Um, I wanted to get your thoughts on this.
Okay.
So I, I, I hate to even bring this up again, man, cause every single time I say anything negative about collaboration, people kind of like shit on me a little bit.
Uh, but the risk of duplicates thing that you talked about here, you said that went down when you were working with, you know, fronds or working with any other collaborator.
Right.
Um, the, my, my qualm with that piece of your formula is that I think there would be overlap, you know, everybody's going to find that basic IDOR.
And instead of getting, you know, a one in X portion of the bounty, you're getting one of X divided by two now, because you're, you're collaborating with your, you know, your, your friend and you're only getting half of one portion of that, of that bug.
So I feel like your risk of duplicates as it pertains to your actual bounty amount issued.
This is largely within a, within a, um, life hacking in context, obviously, cause we're talking about Duke windows.
Um, yeah.
Uh, you know, I feel like that kind of affects the output of your, of your bounty.
So how, how do you think about that?
And, and what is your, what is your response to that?
I mean, I guess I agree with you when it comes to things that you expect everyone else for everyone to find.
Yeah.
Uh, but for the more spark, it's still better to get 1% of something than 0% of something.
So yeah.
Yeah.
I, I suppose that's true.
And I guess also, you know, you and, um, you and, and Franz and, and, you know, your collaboration teams, you know, when they've been bigger in the past, you guys are less focusing on, I think, volume of reports and more focusing on like, okay, we found this thing that just blew up, you know, blew up the whole program.
Right.
Yeah.
These crazy RCEs and then you're, you know, you're just splitting your, you know, 40K, 50K, you know, two ways or, or four ways or whatever.
And that, that feels a little bit better.
Yeah, for sure.
I think, I think that if you don't like duplicates, then you should go deep because like, I, I started counting again, like, March, I think, or if it was April this year.
And I've had zero duplicates and like around a hundred bucks.
So.
Wow, dude, man, you guys are tearing it up.
I know I've been talking to Franz a little bit, you know, the, the program that you guys have been working on.
Um, you know, I assume it's that program.
Is that the one?
Yeah.
95% buck below.
I just, I cannot believe the volume of bounties you guys have pulled from that program this year.
Like unbelievable.
Uh, it's, it's, it's the most amount of money I've ever seen anyone earn in bug bounty.
And that is, uh, in, in one year.
And that includes like these recon gods out there that are just automating everything.
Um, and you guys are doing it manual.
So that's kind of nuts.
You, you are doing it almost entirely manual, right?
Yeah.
I mean, we have some program specific stuff that we try to automate like, wow.
Like, wow.
Okay.
Yeah.
This, this type of pattern seem to emerge at multiple places.
So we should try to look at for that automatically if we can, but like some turbo intruder or something.
Can you, can you elaborate any more on that or your, your lip sealed for now?
On the, on the specifics?
Well, no, not to, not to specifics, but like, like you don't need to leak your, your secrets, but like, you know, are you looking for routes?
Are you looking for, you know, is it an authorization problem?
You know, give the people a little juice, I guess.
Actually, there's another tip for, uh, like automation.
And I know some people do it, but it's a good idea to have program or category specific signatures, let's say, or.
Yeah.
With a bunch of general files.
Oh, um, um, why can't I think of it right now?
It's contagious, whatever you, uh, nuclei, right?
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
Like think of it as.
Nuclear templates custom to that, um, program.
Let's say.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
No, that makes sense.
Uh, so.
And I also think that this is something that's.
Yeah.
I have a big problem with like automatically repeating requests in verb.
It's, uh, someone, can someone please make a good verb extension for that?
Okay.
So hold on.
There, there are some extensions.
What do you mean by automatically repeating it?
I mean, like.
With a specific modification.
I mean like.
Yes.
If, if the request contains this, then just like, give me the whole request.
I do.
Rewrite it with my Python or whatever code and then send it.
And then if it contains this in the response, like, give me a heads up.
I'm about to change your life, man.
Uh, there, there is a, there is a plugin called Autorize that, that does this.
And there's also another.
No, it doesn't work for everything.
Uh, it doesn't.
Okay.
So you, you, you've played around with this before?
Yes.
I tried that, but I tried Autorepeater and I tried, there was a couple more and none of
them can just like give me the whole raw request, let them make changes to it.
Yeah.
But I know that, that, what is called Montoya API has support for that.
So.
Yeah.
That's something.
Now I'm using like a, there was someone in, uh, Bankman forum who posted like a turbo
intruder hack to it, I guess, that can just like monitor all the requests from proxy.
And then you can actually, uh, rewrite it.
I can link to that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Definitely link to that.
Me too.
And I've got it open right now.
I'm actually looking at it on my other monitor.
And yeah, I've switched my workflow over entirely to Kaido now.
There are still a couple of things that I have to do manually and that are kind of bothersome,
but they've made promises to me that they're fixing it, you know, next version.
And I've just found, I've found well into the, you know, five figures range of bounties in the past month with Kaido.
So it's definitely working for me, which is good.
And also they, they sent me a little, I don't know if I'm going to get in trouble with them for, for leaking this, but they sent me a little video of the search functionality that they're implementing, which has like a very, um, uh, Wireshark-esque, uh, sort of query language that you can use.
Uh, and it's just very simple.
You type it up in the, in the, you know, in a search bar up at the top and it just, it works, it works fast.
It's, it's clean and easy for you to, to write, you know, compound queries and that sort of thing.
And I am just so freaking excited for that.
Um, so that should be great.
You can open like a search window and then it sort of just drew everything with that.
Yeah.
It's like Logger++.
Yeah, well it is.
Yeah.
And, and, but, um, actually I haven't used Logger++ in as much detail.
Um, but the thing that I'm really excited for is the query language, right?
Where you being able to, you know, you can just put plain, you know, text in there and it'll, it'll search for it as well, you know, in the body or whatever, but also, which is very useful, but also, you know, having, being able to do compound queries and be like, okay, when the host header looks like this and this cookie is set in the response, you know, like, you know, that sort of thing.
Um, it will, I think.
I really, really missed that in Berk too.
Like I really wish they at least had like a group by function.
Oh yeah.
In this verb search.
Yeah.
No, for sure.
You know what, what I would like in that, like a attacking proxy or whatever we should call the tools.
Yeah.
Give me an API or like a database connection, something.
Let me query the data that is in there.
Yeah.
Don't make me export it to some, you know,
crappy XML based format.
And then, yeah, dude, me too, man.
And actually, um, I was, I was fussing at, uh, site and one of the developers for kind of the other day, I was like, please implement this feature.
And he's like, dude, that's such a pain.
And like, just code it yourself.
And he gave me like, he said, all right, this, these are the GraphQL API requests that you need to do it.
And just like, you do this in the meantime until I get around to implementing this.
And, um, I haven't gone and done it yet.
Cause I've been busy with some stuff this past week, but once they release the docs for the GraphQL API as well, that powers Kaido.
Whew.
That is going to be big time helpful.
Um, so definitely, definitely looking forward to that.
Um, all right, man.
Well, we, we got down a little, a little path there.
Love, love talking about Kaido.
Um, let's see, where, where do I want to go from here?
Um, so before we get into some of the more technical stuff, cause I want to ask you some questions about, uh, mutation XSS and some XSS challenges that you've been putting out recently.
Um, I want to hear about Detectify and your experience with that, because essentially the story as Franz told it was, you know, this young whippersnapper comes into his, uh, whatever, like e-commerce company or whatever it was.
And he's sitting in the corner ARP spoofing everybody in the office, um, and doing hacking stuff.
And then, you know, Franz walks up and he's like, wow, you know, this, this guy's a genius.
And we got to let him do what he's, you know, best at, which is security related stuff.
And, uh, you know, you guys started Detectify together.
And I'm sure that's a little bit of a misrepresentation of the story, you know, from my memory and from Franz's memory.
But I want to hear a little bit, it's a little bit like golden edge on the story, but sure.
Sure, sure. I want to hear your side of it and tell me how, uh, how you and Franz originally met.
Cause you guys are like the, in my opinion, you guys are the most prolific, like the most well-known hacking duo that just like destroys everything they touch essentially when you guys hack together.
Um, and when you hack individually too.
So, you know, obviously when you put it together, it's going to be, be better.
Um, so I want to hear about that origin story.
Sure. So the origin of Detectify goes back to before that actually.
So really, yeah, I can, I can try to fast forward my origin story when it comes to hacking.
Yeah. Yeah, please.
I met the Alam Root, Frederick Alam Root, when I was super young, like we were like seven and eight years old or something.
Yeah.
And we, when we were 12 and 13, we started programming or trying to understand programming.
Um, and we fell into analyzing, um, like Windows VBScript, uh, malware.
Wow.
So VBScript.
As you do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know where the idea come from, but we did.
Yeah.
And so the first programming language, like scripting language or whatever you should call it, that I learned was VBScript actually.
And I, I still remember to this day, that was like the first time I had this wow feeling that I still get today when hacking.
Yeah.
And that's what it takes at the end of the day.
You know, you know, people can do automation stuff and you'll find bugs and that sort of thing.
And that's great.
And we need that.
But also at the end of the day, those are never gonna, you're never gonna find that weird little, like, you know, as Fran said in his episode, that weird little edge case if statement that I had to, you know, deduce from like three hours of playing with an endpoint that just destroys the whole company.
Um, you know, via automation, that's just never gonna happen.
Um, and I also hold the position that I don't think that'll happen with AI either.
Um, and so, yeah, I, I think, I think it will continue to grow just like, just like you said.
Yeah.
Um, I think that there is some risk that is non-zero that, really, but, but, but, but, but the industry or concept as a whole, taking, getting into trouble due to some legislation.
Like that's also a risk that I have thought about in the past.
What do you mean?
Like, like, oh, now this counts as exporting, uh, cyber weapons.
You can't do that anymore.
You can't do that too, from the EU to the US for whatever it may be.
And all of a sudden like, oh, that's legal.
That is a big risk.
That is something that I hadn't really thought of.
And also I was also kind of tossing around this idea, um, a while back and I guess I'll just kind of put it out there on the pod now because I think, I think it would be challenging to get this through, but I've thought about seeing if you could qualify individual vulnerabilities as intellectual property.
And then have a vote, like a rate at which you can donate that intellectual property.
Uh, the idea would be that bug hunters pay a lot of taxes, right?
Um, and how awesome would it be if we could hack on nonprofits that don't have the money to pay normal researchers anyway, donate intellectual property to that company in the form of a bug report,
and then receive a tax write off from that company for a standard vulnerability amount, you know, for a critical 10K for a high, you know, 5K or whatever.
And, um, use that to offset some of this massive tax burden that we've got as, as hunters.
Yeah, no, that would be awesome.
Yeah, we gotta, we gotta look into that, but that's a, that's a, that's an interesting point, man, about, about, um, about exporting cyberware.
I need to, I need to go look into the risk of that because at the end of the day, you know, you, we've already seen that with China, right?
China, China already put a thing out that says like, all right, researchers, you can't like, like participate in like Pondone or something like that.
You've got to do the, the inside of China Pondone where all of the, the bugs go to the government.
Um, at least that's what I've heard.
Um, and so, yeah, there's definitely risk of that sort of propagating, I think.
Yeah.
And it's like the same is true for like researchers from those countries.
Like I'm thinking about these Russian people who suddenly got picked up on platforms because like the sanctions.
Yeah.
No, that was the same thing.
Like something happens in the geopolitical world that you have nothing to do with, but it can affect you.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
No, I, I hated the way that, that they dealt with that situation.
Um, and I don't know whether that actually got reversed or not, cause I meant to look into it and I don't remember off the top of my head, but I know at one point, hacker one was like, okay, no bounties for people in Russia.
And we're donating them all of them.
And I'm like, what?
Like, you can't, you can't, you're just going to donate that money.
You know, like, no, that's not how, how that works.
You know, if, if the sanctions were in place, that's fine.
You can't pay it out, but leave it in the hacker one account at least, you know?
Um, and so I don't know if they went back and fixed that, but if it not, that's a, that is very concerning.
Um, and so, yeah, definitely, definitely some risks there.
Unfortunately.
Indeed.
Um, okay.
So I guess the, the other question that I had here was what are some ways bug bounty has changed from the beginning of, you know, bug bounty.
And obviously it's changed a ton with the, with the, with hacker one and bug crowd and antiquity, you know, sort of coming on the scene and creating that sort of middleman rather than just submitting it via email form to, you know, Facebook or Google or whatever.
Um, even though we do see some, you know, programs sort of moving again away from that, you know, with, uh, I think hack force Salesforce launching their own thing.
And, and, um, you know, obviously Facebook is running their own program in conjunction with some of the big, you know, middlemen.
Um, so that's cool.
Um, but are there, are there any, any trends you can see across bug bounty history?
Because we, we, we have few, few guests that have been involved with this from the very beginning, like you, you know, over 10 years ago.
Um, any trends you're seeing or any things you want to highlight in bug bounty history?
I'm gonna try and make an effort and not be too negative.
I think, I think that's like, like a true stereotype of hackers too.
Like we're, we love finding problems.
Yeah.
So it sounds like you are so negative, but I'll try to find them like the positives too.
So the positives is like the platforms introduced.
Yeah.
That's so, so much better.
You don't need like weird Google alerts and trying to find out who has a program, who doesn't have a program.
Yeah.
Um, so that's awesome.
And also like the standardized, um, reporting too.
Like, okay, everyone can upload files.
It's on the platform, our markdown.
Right.
Um, so most of the like core functionality for Humble is, you know,
four hunters of the platforms.
I think that's been an awesome change from, from the beginning.
I also think that in general bounty amounts have, uh, gone up.
Hmm.
Um, so like the first RC I found, for example, which it was, I might be lying now, but I think it was, okay.
It was one of the first, at least, RCs found a background.
Sure.
And that was like $500 and like then it was like, damn.
$500.
Yeah.
But this is 10 years ago too.
So that, you know, cost of living and inflation and that sort of thing has gone up.
Do you, is it your opinion that, well, I mean, I guess it hasn't gone up, you know, a hundred times and, you know, you can see some huge payouts for, for, um, you know, RCE nowadays.
Yeah, no, I don't think it's outpaced it.
Yeah, for sure.
I don't think that it's just following inflation.
Uh, I think that it has gone up due to not entirely due to thanks to the platforms.
Yeah.
We'll get to that.
Supply and demand as well, you know?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Like competition of, uh, hundreds and also like the whole concept of bug bounty becoming more accepted, I guess, uh, on like, uh, higher levels within organizations.
So it's an easier sell today, probably than, than it was back then.
Yeah.
Maybe you'll get bigger budgets or like actually have a budget for it at all.
Which is amazing too.
I have to say, because like, and, and obviously, you know, people point this out all the time.
If a program is paying $2 million a year, one of some of these big companies, $2 million a year is like, you know, junk change, you know, like find a penny, pick it up on the ground, you know, to some of these big, big companies.
But, um, a lot of these companies, they're just writing a blank check for it.
You know, they're, they're saying like, all right, you know, that pay what you need to pay to, you know, cause the researchers find stuff.
And I, I think that's, that would have been such a hard sell in the beginning.
So I'm thankful to all the people that sort of paved the path for that in the past, because, um, you know, I'm definitely seeing that become more normalized now.
And I think we'll see that even go further in the future.
Uh, and that, that's, that's a steep slope for sure.
I think that if you can manage the time needed for handling reports and like pricing and stuff, like the value add this through the roof for a bug bank.
Yeah.
If you get, if you find a way to get good people to have a look at it.
But, but I want to say also, like, now I say something good about platforms.
Okay.
All right.
One change that has been extremely negative, I think, is that platforms, like I've never purchased a founder program, but I assume that the sales
of the platforms say like, okay, this is the standard program and this is how much, uh, medium is, this is how much, uh, highest, this is how much prettiest.
And that's.
Freaking bullshit.
Yeah.
Like why are they telling clients?
Like maybe million or like billion dollar clients.
Billion.
Yeah.
It's okay.
I think that's, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a,
a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that
that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I
I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a, I think that's a
a small business, then like, then that could make sense, but I think that I think that they should make a best effort to put out what they feel like the low, medium, maybe high, could be worth to them, and I think that the critical should always be, will decide on the spot.
And not defining a minimum.
Yeah. And especially not defining a maximum.
That's, that's tricky, man. I, that's a hot take, dude. I don't know that I would hack on a program that says we'll define, we'll decide the critical, unless they had sort of a track record of saying, okay, we've paid criticals, 20 grand, 30 grand, 40 grand, 50 grand.
You know, like that sort of thing. Because if they say like, it's a critical and we're going to give you, you know, three grand, then that would feel real bad.
Yeah. Yeah. But like, if you don't trust the program, then how can you take those numbers seriously anyway? And also it's like context dependence within the program too, you know, because it's like, oh, I got a shell here. Okay. So test box, there's no data, nothing of value here.
But yes, technically, if you put the C of S in, it is the crit. And then it's like bad to the other way too.
Yeah. And I only think that standard amounts makes sense for bugs that will have the same or the same ish impact. So an XSS, it can be the case like, okay, an XSS under blood.com will always have ish this impact.
Yeah. So, okay. We can put, put a standard on it. Doesn't matter if it's this sub domain or this sub domain or this API or this parameter.
Yeah. It's the same. But for crits, it's like almost always different.
Yeah. How would you, if you were on the other side of the table, how would you decide how much a crit is worth to your organization?
I know that that's a tricky question. We like to, we like to ask the tricky questions here on the CTV podcast. I should have given you a heads up. I've been asking you to prophesy about the bug bounty, you know, industry. I've been asking you putting yourself in other people's shoes, you know, so.
I know, I know this isn't the easiest thing, but yeah. Give me your thoughts.
One thing you can do is like, it depends on if you just starting out and have no data at all, then you can't really do it. But one thing you can do is like based on the previous year or whatever, like this is how many criticals we expect to get. And given that the budget is this, we can have a crit budget within that budget.
So like 10% of that or something. But you can also try to evaluate what the cost of an attacker exploiting it would be too, you know, in terms of like if you have SLAs or if you have...
GPR fines.
GPR fines. Yeah. Or some, some other stuff. But that's like, yeah, there are some hard costs you can calculate pretty good, like with GPR. But when it comes to alternative costs, it's so difficult. But like, okay, what about brand damage? What's that worth?
GPR fines. So much money, dude.
Yeah. And given how little companies seem to be affected when they get high, I guess not much, but...
Well, you know, it's common though, you know, that's the problem is like, it's been, I guess, normalized of sorts. And the average person isn't saying like, okay, well, clearly, I think also, there could be a problem with cybersecurity reporting representation.
So, you know, we can hear, okay, you know, Facebook got hacked or whatever. And it could be like, you know, some freaking Matias and Franz shit where you like, you know, reverse this thing. And it's like crazy RCE that like the best people in the world could have never find except for you guys, you know, and they got hacked that way, which is, in my opinion, pretty much unavoidable, right?
Or it could be, there's a numeric ID or on the homepage that allows you that leaks password hashes, you know, like, you know, and the difference to the average, you know, cybersecurity news listener is nothing.
Right. And, and the, and so I wonder if there's a niche sort of reporting market for something like that, that would actually tell people like, hey, this is essentially negligence, right? That the company didn't do what they were supposed to do. Or this is like, pretty much unavoidable because of how security works.
Yeah. And like, here's the kicker. Most of the time it's going to be cheap. That isn't even in school.
Yeah. Some, some person got phished. Some person reused the password.
That's true.
Yeah, man. It's, it's a scary, it's a scary, a scary world out there for this sort of thing, man. It really is. And there's so many, one of the things that I love about Boke Bounty is it's so tangible. You, you get what you pay for with Boke Bounty, you know, like you're never paying a report where you're not making a change, which is great. And so unlike anything else in the security industry, that's like, you know, pay us 15K a month to run this tool, you know, or, or whatever.
And who knows what it actually does or like, you know, we tell you that this is the results or whatever. Right. But Boke Bounty is exactly what you pay for. So I think a Boke Bounty program is the best way to sure up your technical environment, but there needs to be some serious investment made into securing up your, your personal environment as well. You know, your, your human environment. And that's what I, you know, I like that people are doing with the, the whole keys that you put into your computer.
I can't remember the name of the name of the keys. Yeah. Yeah. And, and, you know, you, you've got that and it like validates the website that you're on. So you can't get like evil proxied, you know, evil engine X, you know, that sort of thing too. So I think there's, there's definitely a big, a big area there. And I think programs that, you know, people that have bug bounty programs should absolutely have already implemented that in their organization, because we all know the easiest way into an organization is to fish someone.
Yeah. So.
No, no, no, for sure. Like I wouldn't recommend to anyone to like take the entire security budget and put it on Boke Bounty.
Yeah. That's, that's, that's very different.
That's a lot of stuff too.
Mattias, this has gone a little bit long already and we haven't even got into some of the good stuff. Do you, do you have a hard end or are you, are you free for a little bit?
No, no, no, we can do it.
Okay.
I'm just more nervous, like for the listeners and stuff. I don't want to take up people's.
No, dude, dude, you know, the last response we got to the Franz episode was like, this is amazing. Two and a half hours of, you know, ramblings. This is amazing. So, um, you know,
Okay, let me say that.
Okay.
Just put it on like 1.25 speed.
Exactly. Right. You know, that's, I listened to all of my podcasts on two or 2.3 speed. And, you know, when I go back to normal speed, I'm like, why does this person's voice sound so weird? You know, like, it's like, this is where the smurf go.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Um, all right, man. So I think, all right, well, we've gone down the whole path of all, almost all of the stuff that I wanted to cover from the non-technical side, but I will ask you one more thing. Okay. And Joel isn't here today. Joel has got a new cat. So he is dealing with some baby kitten craziness this morning. Um, and I wanted to make fun of Joel a little bit. I've even got a note to myself in the document, make fun of Joel here. Um, on the top,
the topic of nerd snipe ability. Now, Joel is a great partner for me in, uh, in hacking and in the pod for so many reasons. But one of the primary reasons that I love him is he is nerd snipeable as heck. You can tell, you can say like, Hey, Joel, I just really don't understand this thing. Like, what, what does this mean, Joel? And then he has like a obsessive, like, Oh, let me, I'm going to figure that out right now. You know, sort of response to that. It's this great concept of nerd snipe ability. And you mentioned that.
You got nerd sniped by a tweet that I did a while back on, um, on XSS stuff.
And I'm wondering, do you consider yourself a particularly nerd snipeable person?
And do you think that is a weakness or a superpower in your own sort of bug bounty journey, but also, I guess, knowledge journey in, in security?
I think, yes, I am.
And I also think it's a net positive.
Yeah.
Um, but the thing is like nerd snipe ability doesn't always, uh, only apply to good stuff, like learning, I see, I just got the same thing with like, I got nerd sniped into the world of Warcraft.
World of Warcraft.
Yeah.
I need to stay away from non-productive stuff that can get too interesting.
So that's, that's, that's good to hear.
You know, I, I think, I think at the end of the day, it is a net positive because you do get that hyper focus.
Um, but I also know that there are a lot of struggles with that come with that too.
Um,
yeah, you know, I, uh, it's strange.
Like when I, the same, when I'm hacking, I love understanding how things work.
Um, it's, it's, it's awesome to go from what the hell is this black box until I, I understand what it does.
And I know, I know exactly why you brought the code like this and I would do it too, if I didn't think about this.
And that's why there is a bug.
Yeah.
Um, but, but the way there is, it's sometimes like frustrating and it's, it's, yeah, no, it's strange.
Like sometimes like if my girlfriend's home or if I'm sitting somewhere, I, I keep like excusing myself because I'm like swearing and like, damn it.
I just copy and paste it.
Like, why did you slip that extra space?
Like, like, I'm really like,
Do you talk to yourself out loud?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So I'm always like, no, I'm not angry.
I just, it's just this thing.
And it needs to, I need to bend it to my will.
Dude.
Yeah.
And that, that's such a great way of saying it too, bending it to your will.
And I think that is so much what happens with bug bounty.
And I think that's another way to classify researchers is there, there are researchers who will bend the application to their will.
And there are researchers that will look at the application and find problems that exist in it.
Just, you know, authentically by looking at the application, right?
You know, it's not like I've got a goal and I'm going to make that goal happen.
It's, it's, I'm going to find the problems with this application based off of threat assessment.
Both of those researchers are incredibly needed and high value.
Right.
But lately I've been doing the bend, bend it to your will thing.
Like I went into a live hacking event.
This is London actually.
And I said, okay, I'm doing something a little bit different.
This event, I'm going to pick one thing that I want to have happen and I'm going to make it happen.
And I, I sat down and it actually only took like three to three or five days out of the two week, you know, prep period.
Right.
And I, I made it happen and it's just like, ah, I love this, you know, like it's just so it warms the heart.
Um, so when you're, when you're going deep and you're really bending the application to your will, I think there's a lot of really good, um, emotional payoff for that sort of thing.
Yeah, no, for sure.
For sure.
And I agree.
Like one of the bad parts though, it's like sometimes I get too much in a rush, I guess, to get it to go.
So I'm like, uh, not documenting enough.
My files named one, two, three, four.
Yep.
Like my burp tabs are everywhere.
My Chrome tabs.
Yeah.
And also like, I'll, I'll catch myself.
Like, okay, I'm going to go get coffee.
And then like, I don't walk to the coffee machine.
I like skip the run.
Like, yeah.
What am I doing?
I don't, I'm not in a rush.
That's great, dude.
I love that.
Or, and then you, you, you know, you run to the coffee machine, you pour the coffee, you know, you get back as fast as you can without spilling it.
You set it on the desk.
Don't even drink it.
Get back to the thing.
Right.
You know, like, and it's, it's freezing cold by the time you take the first sip.
Um, so no, I totally get that.
And it's so funny, man.
You know, one, one, two, three.txt asked if.txt.
I think it was Cosman, the first guy that said that on the pod, but it's really funny how so many of us are having that, you know, be a problem.
Um, and this is something that I'm actually really looking forward to in the AI space is like, can I have an AI assistant that will just organize stuff for me?
Right.
Like how helpful would it be if, you know, you were in Kaido and you like send a click, you know, a request to repeater or something like that.
And it like smart named it for you or something like that.
Right.
By looking at the request and, or, or like, you know, you, you create ask if.txt and it, and it says, okay, ask if.txt.
And then in parentheses, it says notes on XYZ target.
Right.
You know, like that, that sort of thing would be so helpful.
Um, and so that's something I'm really looking forward to in the AI space.
I think that'll be, I think that'll be here before long with the rate at which people are going after AI startups right now.
Um, yeah.
I can, I give another.
Yeah.
Dude, dude, I love that.
Yes.
Okay.
So one recommendation I have when it comes to documentation and knowing what the hell you did.
Yes.
Um, okay.
Just, if you have some startup script or when you're opening work or your tool of choice, Keto, yes.
I recommend sending everything through there and then doing the filtering in the tool itself instead of having like filters in the, uh, in like your proxy extension, et cetera.
Because then you, you have everything.
Nothing can just vanish and go missing.
And yes, it will require like more random resources, but it has helped me so many times.
Yeah.
By doing that.
And also the first thing I also do in the, in my startup script is I SSH into one of my boxes, but you can also send a request through verb.
Maybe someone has talked about this already.
Yes.
So, you know, like this is what my IP was.
My IP was my external IP was at the time.
Yeah.
In case you need it for later.
Dude.
That's great.
And, and you, you mentioned that in the, in the talk and I did find the talk, by the way, it's how to differentiate yourself as a bug bounty hunter.
Um, and I will link that in the description.
Uh, but you mentioned that in there as well saying like, never, ever, ever.
Let go of your data.
Just, just, you know, storage is cheap.
Go to the store, get a eight terabyte, you know, external hard drive, drop those BIRT files onto it, you know, uh, after you're done.
And then someday when you're like, oh, I've got this zero day, you know, that affects everything that has the perimeter, you know, XYZ one, two, three, you just go to that, that whole folder, you set up like a rip grep and you just say, all right, give me everything that has XYZ one, two, three in it.
And now you've got years of data sort of piling up there.
Um, it's awesome.
I definitely do that.
I've got an external hard drive right in front of me that has over a hundred gigabytes, probably, probably over 500 gigabytes of, of burping and, uh, Kaido files.
Actually, I don't know that I have all my Kaido stuff on it yet.
Cause Kaido just kind of so efficient with it.
Um, that I can grab through, which is really handy.
That's actually something I'm curious about too.
Like, do you have any projects which are really big?
Cause I feel like around the 500,000 request mark purpose.
Like really struggling even opening and yeah.
Let me look at this right now.
I have a Kaido project.
It's this one right here that is 22 gigabytes.
Um, and it's the same thing that is the, is let me tell you how many requests are on it.
Um, yeah, I was gonna say just roughly.
Yeah.
Uh, 350,000 requests in the actual project.
Um, and then I've probably got, I've got over 200, probably close to 300 repeater tabs.
And then like 20 automate sessions, which is the equivalent of it, of intruder.
Right.
And the thing still works just like, you know, it did whenever I booted up Kaido, you know, for the first time.
Uh, with the exception of obviously searches are going to take a little bit longer and who knows, maybe they'll have optimized that with, um, you know, the next search patch or whatever.
But.
Yeah.
I, I hope they did build something to make it searchable.
Like in memory.
I think that's one of the differences if I'm not mistaken, we have to logger plus plus versus the normal search.
Yeah.
Logger plus plus, we like to load everything into RAM.
Oh my God.
Obviously that's not faster to search.
Yeah.
That's not, that's not great.
That is real bad.
Yeah.
And I also just want to shout out the fact that when you asked me that it took me less than 10 seconds to switch into that project and, you know, get in from the project that I had open and check their request count, which is just so beautiful.
And my, my, uh, my workspaces in Kaido are so much cleaner.
Cause you can literally, it's like one click to change projects, no lag time.
So really love that.
Um, okay.
So technical shit.
Yeah.
Technical shit.
Yes.
I'm sorry.
We've been waiting, you know, it's an hour and a half in.
I might actually add a little disclaimer at the beginning of this episode.
Um, you know, that a lot of the, uh, technical shit will be, uh, you know, at the, you know, one hour 30 mark or whatever.
Uh, yeah.
It's funny.
You should love the tips.
Yeah.
All the tips are great too.
So, you know, those, those are technical as well.
Um, yeah, dude, you can't, you can't leak my, my, uh, super secret titles.
I'm going to go to the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the, uh, uh, the, uh, uh, the, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh
and finding all the interesting stuff and, uh, getting ready to talk about that.
So you put out this tool, uh, hack a planet 10, uh, it's, it's hack the planet in Swedish.
Can you say it?
Hack a planet.
I don't know, man.
Uh, the Lord Swedish update.
That's great.
You own that domain, the dot se domain and, uh, HTML parse in it.
This is super awesome.
So essentially what it does, you go to this, this thing here, you submit an HTML document and then it runs DOM purify on it.
It, and it puts it through all of these, um, different server side HTML renderers and shows you the result.
Um, so tell me why you did this and can you, well, first explain you're looking for mutation XSS here, apparently.
Why are you looking for mutation XSS and what is mutation XSS?
Okay.
So mutation XSS is like, if you take a payload and just give it to the browser knows no alert box will pop.
Essentially, but if you put it through some course at first, like even one that's inside of the browser itself, which is MTSS like inner HTML, uh, setting or, uh, like the DOM parser, um, et cetera.
And then it will essentially try to fix errors.
And in the markup and while inserting those fixes, it actually turns it into a success.
Let's say.
So, so if I'm understanding correctly, the browser or the, the sort of, I guess, DOM rendering engine, whatever it is, it could be a server side HTML parser.
It could be a browser, it could be, you know, some other modif modification within the browser.
When you give it some HTML document that is not spec compliant typically, right?
You know, it, it, it will look at this thing and say, okay, can't render this because it's not spec compliant.
Let me see what I can do to fix it. And when it does that, it will inadvertently cause XSS.
Is that right?
Yeah, that's exactly right. It's a bug in the, I'll fix your bad markup.
Love that. Thank you for your help, uh, browsers and DOM renders all around.
We, we love that you, we can rely on you for this sort of thing.
So, so what was the motivation for this tool, man? What did you, why did you build this and what kind of stuff have you been finding with it?
Well, the motivation was it actually had nothing to do with XSS.
Yeah.
But yeah, well, it was like a, it wasn't like a XML bug, but I knew they accepted.
You, it was weird because you could send HTML to it instead of XML.
And I was like, hmm, I wonder what parser they're using because there was certain tags they wouldn't allow me to use.
And I needed them to exploit stuff.
Yeah.
And I had this idea, like, I wonder if I can hide the tags from them somehow, but when it forwards it, it will actually be unhidden.
Because some other parser where it actually ends up after that, treats it in a different way.
So I was like, okay, how, how, surely there's some tool you can just spin up all of these things and you see like how does each parser parse it?
Surely.
And it's like, nope.
And then standard moment in all its life, man, someone should build this.
I'm that someone.
I guess I'm someone.
So that's great, man.
So you, you went and you built it, you took how many, geez, I mean, you press parse in here and it just keeps on going.
So you've got so many.
16 parsers.
A bunch of them.
Wow, dude.
How much of a pain in the butt was that to, uh, to do?
I mean, the biggest problem was choosing whether I should implement like a whole website for it,
or if I should make a, like a hack, which I ended up doing.
Like, do I need to make, have like a web server and a whole MVC framework just to call this parsing
function and see what it does?
But instead do it, build it with Apache and CGI actually.
And then it will just run like CLI version of the.
Wow.
Very cool, man.
Yeah.
So that's, I took the shots about this actually, which way to do it in, in, in, in,
practical way.
Cause I'm like, it's going to take a long time if I'm going to have to build an actual application.
Heck yeah it is, dude.
Oh, I see you open sourced it too.
Yeah.
So that's what I did.
And, uh,
Oh, it's got a Docker.
It's got, dude, I did not see this when I did the research.
This, this, uh,
No, it's, it's one of them is a, you know, it's a Docker container.
No dude.
And then he, so, okay.
So you, you've got it in a Docker container and then you can literally just do echo your,
your, your, your dom pipe it into Docker exec and then give it the name of the parcel you want.
And it'll just do it.
Yeah.
That's.
Dude.
That's correct.
This is.
So you can like fuzz it through that if you like to, or you can use the, the beautiful web interface.
This is really well architected, dude.
I'm really impressed.
Nice, nice work with this.
Thank you.
Do you have any, um, so did you, did you pop the XML thing or no?
I did.
And like, uh, because I managed to, uh, hide tags with it because it parsed the, um,
HTML comments incorrectly.
So you didn't recognize dash dash exclamation.
Great to them.
That's an end of a comment.
Ah.
You can also like, uh, okay.
If you, if you, if you saw some like, uh, only in Brunt.se, that's like, uh, I have put in like a
combination of those things that I found for different parsers that we, we like hide the content of the
document.
Oh, up at the top there?
Is that, no, what are you like, um, on just the homepage of, of the.se?
If you take, for example, just standard, uh, uh, beautiful soup and HTML powder, and you try to scrape
my site and like take the links, you cannot do it.
No way.
Really?
And it's same with like floppy, uh, a couple of hours, but, um, so yeah, that was like the
second, like interesting challenge I thought of, uh, when building that's just like, hmm,
I wonder if you can hide from, from scrapers, like what implications can be.
Can't, can't be the good old regex though.
That's true.
Yeah.
No, that's really cool though.
I love that you built that in.
That's like some serious hacker, hacker shit right there.
When you like make your own way, you implement this on your own website just for the kicks.
Yeah.
So that they can't, you know, pull your LinkedIn and your Twitter from
AbletonBrun.se.
High value, high value links you've got there only for human eyes.
Yeah, no, no, so I did find some stuff and I, I have been thinking about implementing like
the same with XML parsers too, cause that's something that I, that I think, uh, could have
specific bugs too.
And like, someone wants a research area, pick a bunch of different standardized XML parsers,
see how they treat like external types or other type of XXe issues.
And play around with it because there was someone in the, in the, you're going to think in podcast
this, but actually I don't think they meant what I thought they meant, but they gave me another
idea that like, okay, maybe there's a parser that doesn't require the declaration to be at the start of
the document.
And, and I, I saw that conversation that looked interesting.
But, but that would make XXe, like a new type of XXe, I guess, which would be like
external doc type injection.
So when you, when you're injecting into the body of the XML document, instead of controlling those things.
So I actually have a piece of research that I want to say, I don't remember whether I actually
put it into the SAML episode for, for critical thinking, but there is a Chrome browser exploit
that was a couple of weeks ago, not the one that, that dropped in the critical thinking research,
uh, XC one recently, um, where they were using XSLT transforms.
Yeah.
To do some crazy stuff with the placement of that entity, you know, the doc type tag.
Um, and so there essentially it was like, it was using the parser to stick it up at the top.
And on one, on the first parser, it would, it would not have it at the top and on the next one,
it would, and then trigger the XC.
Um, so the other cool thing you can do with that is the XSLT transforms, which I am really excited to
dive into deep more. I hope, I hope some of the listeners go and do this research because I,
I'm super swamped with stuff right now, but I would love to see any research, research on XSLT.
Maybe I can nerd snipe you on it. Dude, the transforms are so cool. I've did. Have you,
have you like learned at all about XSLT transforms?
Yeah. I found XSLT bug one and a half week ago.
Oh my gosh. Of course you have. All right. Whatever, whatever, Matthias. All right.
But that means it was one and a half week ago. So it means I forgot everything.
Yeah. Your context window is gone. No, that's great, man. So, all right. Well then,
so you've actually done some more hands-on stuff with it than I have, because I've just done mostly
reading and ideating on it. Um, what is your, yeah, share, share, share a little bit about that,
would you? I can share about that, but I just, it was really interesting point that you brought up with
this XSLT because XSLT is basically meant to like transform the incoming XML document to something
else. Yeah. So. It's pre-parsed.
You can transform it into something that now has an XSC in it. That's, yeah. I guess that's what you
meant, but I just have to revisit that, I guess. It's awesome. That's great, man. I could see,
yeah, he's, for those of you that are listening, not watching on YouTube, there's like this far off
look in his eyes. That is the, the, the mark of, of a bug forming. I can see it. That's great, man.
I love that. Um, yeah, but there's also a lot of stuff or there are some different,
a couple of different XSLT libraries, but you can do like file system stuff. Yeah.
To, and get like environment variables and stuff. So you can even do more stuff than with
that's normal. Yeah. A hundred percent. And so, yeah, I'd like to normally before people come on
the podcast, I message them and I say, Hey, you know, check out this document, you know, that sort
of thing. Right. And then I also tell them, Hey, bring a bug or two so that we can talk about it
on the pod. And I totally forgot to do that for you for this episode. So I'm sorry about that.
We can talk about that one. Yeah. Can you, can you give us some info on that? That'd be great.
Uh, so that one was, you could upload an XML. Okay. Through a bunch of different hoops you had
to jump through, but it ended with like, you could provide an XML and then in another place,
you could provide an XSLT document. And the funny thing is the XSLT document is also specified as XML.
Right. And that, that one was vulnerable to XSLT, but I didn't find it because I tried it in the
original document that was not vulnerable. So then I was like, okay, XSLT, I'm going to learn it,
XSLT specific box. And then like after I played with it and talked to Franz about it, he's like,
but this is the XSC. Freaking Franz, dude. Shut up Franz.
Shut up Franz. Like, why do I, get out of here. Who invited you to this anyway?
Right. But in another way. So one,
normal trick that I learned with that was that I forget exactly what the operation was called,
but there's like a couple of ways you can read files and that you can read JSON files with one
operation. I can try and write it later and we can, we can link to this documentation.
Yeah, that'd be super cool. And you can write, or you can read XML documents,
but you can also read raw files. But the problem is, oh, this is connecting to the next part actually,
of this secret document. You could also, in the parser, you weren't allowed to read
read nullabytes into the resulting document. Interesting.
You're like, oh, damn, can't read like ProxSelf environment.
Yeah. It's like separated windows. But what you could do is specify the encoding of the file. So what
you could do is, you could tell it, treat it as like the GDF 16, for example. And then it could spit
out like a bunch of Chinese characters, and then you could like transform that back. And I knew that
it was a Java application, so I could just use Hackworker and then know that it's like Java versus Java.
So I actually expected like the environment via like reading the file as you did 16 and then turn it back.
Yeah.
Dude, that is, you've been doing so much crazy char set stuff lately, man.
That's really cool that you bypassed that with that though. That's an amazing idea.
I like, I like, I suppose, like confusion bugs.
Yeah.
Like it's a broad area.
It is.
They are my, one of my favorites. And encoding is like, I'm still not entirely sure. There's a blog post
actually. I can link it to it. It's like really old, like 2007 or something.
Sure.
And it's called something like everything you need to know about encodings and char sets
as a developer.
Okay.
I need that. Okay. So.
Yeah. Yeah. And it starts from the beginning. Like,
in the beginning, there was everything. When we did that, there was the ASCII. And then,
the high bytes was not used for anything. And then, so people started implementing whatever they
wanted over like zero X 80. And, uh, that wasn't really standardized, but then IBM was like, okay,
we call off, take all of them. And we give them each a code page. So now when you see like a short
set, it's like CP one, two, three, four. Yeah.
That's, that's the code page.
Wow. Dude, that's, that's cool, man. I would love to read that document. I think that,
I think a lot of our listeners would love to read that too. So I'll, um, well, I'll follow up with you
after that and try to try to get that in the description. Yeah. Um, and I could, uh, encoding box
is really, really, really interesting. And also things like injecting like byte order mark to confuse
Injecting what? Byte order mark. Oh, byte order mark.
Yeah. So you can use it in like you get 16, for example, or like,
Is this the like, encoding flip it around thing? Like the left to right override?
Yeah, exactly. It's like, if it's little engine or big engine, it's like, should the top byte come
first or second? Oh, oh yeah. Yeah. So you're talking about like, um, like, uh, UTF 16 LE, UTF 16 B.
Is that what you're talking about? Exactly. Yeah, exactly. So if you just say UTF 16,
Right. Then it's ambiguous. Right. You can start the, the document or the string of strings. Yeah.
With like, it is byte order mark. It's like FVFF, I think, for one of them. And then it's like,
aha, you're telling me to what coding it is. Okay. So hold on, wait a second. So you can
actually put that in the data? Yeah. What? Yeah.
Byte order mark. Byte order mark.
Yeah. Dang, dude, I need a bigger notepad for this episode. Um, byte order mark. And so you can
put that in the data and it will define how the rest of that data string is read?
It should have to start with it, but I wouldn't be surprised if some people or some
of our interpreters of ourselves could have it in the middle. Holy crap. That's amazing. That is,
that is super, I'm just kind of, yeah, now, now I've got the thing in my head, you know,
I'm looking off into the, into the distance and, and ideating on, on what, what could become of that.
That's, that's really, really interesting, dude. I'm definitely going to have to look into that
after this. Um, yeah. Thanks so much for sharing that. I'm sure that'll result in a bunch of,
in a bunch of bugs. Um, yeah, there's also some encodings that have special, I don't think it's
called byte order marks, but it's like special, special sequence of characters that like transform
it. So like in the middle of the document, we can have by blah and blah, and then it's
turns it to like, okay, now it's this other way of interpreting it. And it ends with something else.
No way. There is encodings, which is like, okay, now it's
standard ASCII. Everything's fine. It's like, no, now it is not. Now it's this other thing.
Dude, that is so interesting. So if you could get them to parse it with that char
set, then you could really use that to bypass some con security controls because, you know,
whatever parser will be looking at it and being like, okay, you know, this is just meaningless text.
And then when the actual end, you know, program runs it, it's something completely different
because it's, it's actually parsing the char set differently.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. So if they had like a screen campaigns, for example, then it could be
different. Dude, this has got to be...
This was the topic too, and this is what I saw, like normalization. They can like transform it into...
Yeah.
...some of the char set.
This is, this is very, and you know, of course, my mind goes directly to web servers and reverse
proxies and WAFs. And this is actually pretty much exactly what Sam Erb and I were talking about. And I
don't know if you saw it in the document, but I did a talk on this at Defcon,
on how you can define host headers for some, for some HTTP servers, and you can define them in
different encodings, right? So literally our exploit for this bug was host, and this is a host header,
host colon equals question mark ISO 8859-1 question mark, queue, and then a bunch of hex data. And that
actually got converted into our exploit on, on the, the backend of that, um, server that we were talking
to, it bypassed the Nginx, uh, configuration that had some limits on the host header characters being
used and allowed us to inject right into the Nginx config file on the backend because of the way that
we could smuggle characters like a space and stuff like that into the host header. Um, and so now I'm
thinking like, man, there's gotta be even more possibilities of this sort of thing with stuff
that can change mid, you know, mid, uh, mid flow and change into something else because maybe the
Nginx proxy on the front end reads, decodes the character set, but the one on the backend doesn't,
and it doesn't normalize it. And then it just treats it like normal text. And then you can pop XSS,
or you can, you know, bypass any sort of filtering in place. Yeah. But like you also need to, you,
when you're talking about the XSS, you need, either you need server-side normalization for it to
transform, because when you're sending, like if you're using your, that's 16th example, what you're
actually sending is just two bytes. And if you want like a less than characters, those two bytes will be
no byte and 3C. So if it filters 3C in like an 8-bit ASCII encoding, it will go like, okay, is this a 3C?
Is this a 3C? No? Sure.
Sure, sure, sure.
You need to say yes. And so you need to need normalization or you need some kind of
encoding supported in the client that where like 003C or 0303F means less than.
I'm wondering if there's other, there's got to be other encodings besides, you know, UTF-8, UTF-16
that put those at different code points, right?
In browsers?
No, well, you know, and I linked actually, funny you mentioned that, Matias, because I did my homework
for this episode. And if you click the first link under the character sets heading in the secret
document, I have a link directly to the Chromium source code and all of the different
character encodings that we, you know, that can be used in here. And I see one of them, you know,
is this ISO 8859-1 that I'm more familiar with from the DEF CON talk. And so I'm wondering if there's
different ways, you know, or do any of these different encodings put a different, put the,
you know, less than sign or greater than sign or whatever at a different code point. So that if
it bypasses the front end and says, okay, you know, the front end says, this is, you know, a question
mark, but the back end says, okay, I'm actually not reading this as, as, you know, Windows dash one,
you know, one, two, five, two, and actually I'm interpreting this as UTF-8 or interpreting this
as ASCII. And then, you know, you get the output as an actual script tag. Does that, does that make
sense? Or am I thinking about this incorrectly? I mean, it's a good idea, but the ISO 8859.
Yeah, it's different. No, it is ASCII based. No, no, I know. I know. It's not what we're,
it doesn't meet the standards of what we're, we're looking at. Yeah. But this, there is something
like that. And yes, unfortunately, I don't think that there is, uh,
any non-ASCII supported for sets for like HTML and dangerous content-writing browser.
Ah, so, so the, the overlap.
Anymore, they, they used to be, they used to be, yeah. Especially in like internet
of core had some special cases and like all of them at some points for the UTF-7, which is just like
seven, seven bit. So ASCII, ASCII would be, so the base for all of these is what you're saying.
So the first 256 characters of every single one, that three C is always going to be the,
the angle bracket for, for XSS. Yeah.
But ASCII is the, all the characters you need in punctuation for the English language. So it
starts at 0x20 and stopped at, at, at, at, uh, seven, like smaller than C.
Yeah. At least that's how I learned in my mom.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and, and, oh, actually speaking of, um, I was going to say this in the start, but
one of the best ways, um, to learn, I believe is to be wrong.
Yeah. So if I say something that is wrong, please tell me. Yeah. And also like, uh,
trust that verify when it comes to people teaching you, that's like a super free way to learn.
Heck yeah, dude. I love this. And I also love that you're in the CTVB discord. I appreciate that by the
way, you know, I, people are asking questions in there all the time about stuff like, you know,
XML and about, um, you know, uh, character sets or some of these more advanced topics. Right.
And you're in there like responding to questions and like getting nerd sniped by the con by the content,
which I really, I, I definitely appreciate. And I, and I totally agree, man. Once again,
Matias, I think you'd like podcasting, man, because, uh, I'm not, not, not trying to, you know,
drum, drum me up some, uh, bug bounty competition, uh, bug bounty podcast competition, but you know,
you're out there every week, you're talking for an hour and a half, you know, and you're,
and you're making mistakes and people are messaging you saying, Hey, you messed this up.
And then you just get free correction, you know? And if you're not taking yourself too seriously,
you know, um, then it's great. And you, and you, you learn so much. So, yeah, we might have to, uh,
you know, get the Matias show started or, or we might have to make you get, get you on here on a
regular basis. Maybe you'll be the, uh, uh, Joel is having some cat problems, uh, you know, subhost
in the, in the future. Um, but yeah, definitely.
Yeah. Actually it reminds me of this, uh, there's some late night show. I think it's Conan or some,
one of them where they have like special episodes where like the viewers can come on and like,
Oh, you, uh, you wrote about this because this is not like it. That's an idea.
Oh, just like a roast episode. Oh my gosh.
Like people can like point out like actually.
Dude, that's a great idea. I gotta,
If you could stomach that.
I gotta, no, no, no, no, a hundred percent. I've got to, um,
I'm going to write that down. I'm going to try to make a, uh, a channel in the, in the,
in the, uh, discord, in the CTV podcast discord of like corrections, you know, stuff Justin said
that was wrong and it's going to make me feel so bad, but I'm going to learn so much. That's a great
idea, dude. Um, but yeah, I would be really interested to see, you know, especially with
some of these, uh, character sets that are oriented specifically towards other languages,
you know, like the Japanese, um, the ISO, uh, 2022 JP, uh, character set or some of these other stuff.
What is actually, you know, if they're all ASCII compliant or whether there's ways to represent
different code points, you know, in different ways that are outside of ASCII's definitions and still
get an ASCII result back, um, that would be, that would be really interesting. And then also,
but of course you've got the, the sort of normalization piece, which is often in place,
you know, I've got the Japanese keyboard set up on my computer, uh, and, and I always just switch
it over to Japanese and drop in the, uh, you know, uh, the full width, um, less than and greater than,
um, you know, for the XSS stuff. And I've definitely had that pop quite a few times.
Yeah. Well, that can actually be an easy way to bypass the WAFs too.
Yeah. If the server side supports UTF-7, but the WAF doesn't just send it, that's the code.
I want to say, was it, was it Sourouche? Uh, wow.
Bypass. I think that's, that's an unrated dude.
Yeah. Yeah. A hundred percent. I'd love to have him on the, on the, on the podcast sometime. I
believe. Yeah. I'll link it in the, in the description as well, for those of you guys that
are listening, but Sourouche, um, uh, Dali, Lee, sorry, Erstal is his, is his handle. I don't really
know how to pronounce last names sometimes or first names in that regard, but I will link it in the
description below. He has an article from 2018 on using character sets to bypass WAFs. And this is
incredibly, um, incredibly applicable and, uh, often used to bypass WAFs. And I also saw a tweet
going around the other day. I'm not sure if you saw this from, um, Jay Esch, I think is his name.
I don't know how to, I don't have it in front of me, so I'm not sure, but he's been dropping a bunch
of cool tips lately. And we talked about a couple of them on the pod. And one of the ones he did was a
WAF bypass that just says, uh, content encoding as the header, as HTTP header. And then it, the content is
just WAF bypass. So essentially if there's any content encoding header, the WAFs like, ah, you know
what, actually, I don't know how to deal with that shit. I'm just going to pass it through and hope
that you figure it out. Uh, and I just thought that was hilarious. Like what kind of BS WAFs people are
using? Yeah. It's, I mean, they have basically never been effective except for maybe specific
automated effects. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. I think they ought to look at the, um, the WAFs should look
at, or maybe they shouldn't look at, but, uh, the port swigger cheat sheets on like impossible access
scenarios. Like, you know, if you can just block less, you know, left-end bracket or less than bracket
A through Z, then you're screwed, right? There's no way you can really get around that. Um, as far as HTML
context injection goes, um, because that's just a part of the spec, you know, it has to be an alpha
character, you know, coming right after it. So it's a bummer. Hopefully someone will crack that
one someday because if they do, there's going to be a lot of XSS is popping left and right. Um,
all right, man, let's see. We are at two hours already. Uh, let's, let's skip over some of this and talk
about your favorite go-to vulnerabilities and stuff that you find yourself finding often. You know,
if you had to profile, so a while ago, let me add some context to this question while you think about
that. Um, a while ago, you released this, uh, this dashboard with Franz, I believe, uh, Bounty Dash,
and you, you know, you'd pull in before the, the programs were doing this sort of thing. It would pull
in all your reports and like categorize them and give you earnings, you know, per certain period of
time and you know, what kind of severity of owns they were and that sort of thing. And vulnerability
classes, I think were included as well. Um, if you were to profile Mathias as a, as a, as a bug bounty
hunter, what kind of stuff would be your bread and butter? What would be your go-to vulnerabilities
that you often find? Hmm. I often look for high or great level stuff. So I, it's always like context
dependent depending on the organization. I always, always start with trying to understand
what does the organization have? What are they value protecting? Yeah. So that I can then follow up with,
okay, what are they protecting it with? And how is it supposed to work? Okay. It's authentication
authorization. Okay. How is that supposed to be implemented? Just to be, you can have in the back
if you have like, okay, these are the things that they probably care about. Um, but the specific bugs,
like I found about, I, I find a bunch of bugs on the way, like XSS that just are obvious. Um,
So you don't ignore those lower medium impact phones in search of the highs or crits, but you know,
no, no, no, like why, why, why use Mathias in this field? If I can just like use a bunch of
quotes and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It takes me the same amount of time. Yep. But, uh, yeah, I don't know.
I like, I like confusion and I like different kinds of injections. And I also like,
like this, uh, reverse proxy type of bugs. Hmm. Reverse proxy types of bugs. Let's, let's talk a little
bit about that. How do you, are you doing the host level fuzzing for that? Is that the sort of thing
you're talking about? Or are you talking about secondary context path traversals or yeah, yeah,
exactly. Secondary complex stuff. Hmm. Yeah. One of the tips we've dropped before on the pod for that sort of
thing is, you know, traversing all the way back past the document route and then cutting off
everything after will result in a 400 getting dropped on the status code. So with that, you can
determine the document route on the backend server that you're, that you're traversing with. Do you
have any other cool tips or tricks you can drop on secondary context bugs, identifying them and exploiting
them? Or is it just mostly a fuzz game? Cause that, that, that is part of it. I know for sure.
I mean, request smuggling is the same. Like that's also a thing where you can get like
the different applications in the chain to treat the request differently. What else?
Do you, do you actively exploit request smuggling in these sort of scenarios
on a, let's say, you know, multiple times a year basis, you think?
I don't automatically scan for it or anything, but I will look at it if I
I, sporadic, I guess. I don't know if I feel like it, I guess bad answer, but that's just intuition,
I suppose. But also like one, one actual tip is it's kind of a fussy in the standard, whether
a hashtag or fragment character is allowed in a path or not.
Yeah.
Yeah. So a lot of times what I see is that like the first load balancer or whatever,
it's like, okay, that's just a part of the path. But then when it forwards it to the back end, the path
is, uh, cut off. So that's like another way you can, if you need a way to truncate the rest of the path,
because maybe there's some reverse proxy match. So you need to have the surface.
Yeah.
So that's like a good tip.
Yeah. Using that, using the, um, the query parameter, you know, the question mark as well,
we'll get you that sometimes for sure. And that truncation is so helpful, man.
Uh, one of the things I've struggled with though, let's see if you've got any thoughts on this. I
don't know if you've, you've had this one and I'm not sure there's a great solution to it, but
there's this concept of like, okay, I'm injecting in the middle of a secondary context,
you know, situation, right? So I've got some text before and I've got some text after, right?
Um, the text before you can brute force by, you know, path traversing, deleting it,
and then brute forcing. And if it completes the request, the way that you would
anticipate that it should be completed, then you've identified the correct path there.
Right. Um, but on the right side, how can we, without some sort of verbose error,
I struggle to enumerate what is on the right side of our injection point.
Are you, are you tracking with me or no?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're still talking about like the path part.
Yeah.
Like the very first line of the request.
Well, one thing you could do is like, try to make it extremely long and then you can see,
maybe see like path, um, and then it just ends with that.
Interesting.
And that's one way to do it. Another way you can do it is.
Plus size inflation. Yeah. Interesting.
Oh yeah. And then it would drop back a, what is it? A 414, like a 414 status code,
I believe it's just like, uh, yeah, you or I too long response status code. Right.
So, and then you could use that to protect you, like potentially determine
if you, if you know the full path to the left and you don't know the path to the right,
you could at least get a character count at least probably on the,
Yeah.
That how much is there by determining, by inflating the size and then determining where you get the 414
status code.
Yes.
Huh.
That's not what I meant, but that's a good idea.
Well, that's what happens when we get on these pods. We just kind of ideate and bounce off,
bounce off of each other. That's good though. I like that.
Yeah. Like the same thing with the, like the query and stuff too. Like you can
make a question mark and then put some thing you think is an envelope character and it might speak
back. Like query names cannot be named blah, blah, blah. So that's like another.
Yeah. Try it. So, so fuzz the path, fuzz the query,
fuzz, fuzz the query parameters themselves that you might be able to identify are getting parsed,
right? Cause those might throw a weird error. Inflate the request.
And also.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
You can also like throw a Hail Mary and try like SSR in it because sometimes there will be like.
Throw a what?
Hail Mary.
Oh, Hail Mary. No, no, no. You're good. I didn't hear it. You're good. It cut out.
Yeah.
But like slash static slash blah goes to some other backend thing.
Then instead of stuck, they might have a bad rule. So you can do like slash static
at example.com and then there will be like SSRF and then you can look at the logs and you get the
rest. Interesting.
And you should be-
I understand I'm kind of cheating in your scenario.
No, no, no. That's great because let's say for example, the backend is like slash API slash
you know, blah, blah, blah, blah.com or whatever, right? You, you traverse back,
you do or no, slash API and then whatever path. And instead you put, you can delete the API,
right? Part and then write API again at whatever. And that will interesting. That's some, that's something
I've always struggled with because I was like, man, wouldn't it be great if we could traverse all
the way back up and then, you know, make it a slash slash, right? And have it point to a different
domain. It doesn't really make a lot of sense in a lot of scenarios, but in some normalization scenarios,
I actually have popped that vulnerability before, which is insane. And I'll actually show you a
very impactful one I've got after this episode. But yeah, no, that's another great way to get around it
is if you can figure out where that mapping might be, you can find some NGINX style,
reverse proxy misconfigurations, even on that backend and try to try to use those to hit different domains.
Yeah. Like here's another like, hey, hey, my, yeah, probably should never work. But I've seen it
once. Wow. So the host header, I don't know if it's in spec, but usually they allow port there. I think
it's because you can have a port, you can provide a full URI instead of like a relative in that get
space, HTTP. So a lot of the parts are lenient for the web service or whatever, with the port part of
the post and port. So one time at least I've seen, you can do like host example.com colon 80 at
the end of the post. Probably didn't bring the best. No.
Yeah. Dude, you know what that I want to say, who was it? It was James Kettle, HTTP. I can't remember the
name. It's like, like hitting. Practical HTTP, like host header injections or something.
Yeah. It's like, what is the name of that research? It's like the untapped attack surface or like,
I can't remember. HTTP host header. No, no, no, no, no. It's, it's now it's not just practical HTTP
host header attacks. I don't think there's the first one that comes up when I Google it,
but there's, there is, um, there was, cause now he's got all of this stuff on, ah, exploiting HTTP's
hidden attack surface, I think is the one that I was thinking of a report or a, um, talk he did back in,
I want to say it was 2017 or maybe even before that at, uh, at Defcon, um, has this very similar
thing. And I know at the time, you know, if you were in the live hacking event scene, which I'm sure
this is why you thought of this as well, people were destroying stuff on, uh, on, on Yahoo with this.
It was like, like the, the Yahoo must've paid out hundreds of thousands, if not millions of dollars
in bounties from this specific vulnerability. Um, so hopefully you've got that fixed now Yahoo. Oh,
sorry about that. If I just, uh, you know, called out your, your, your problems that are still active,
but if you don't have it fixed by now, five years later, you're doing something wrong. So
I want to, I want to give some motivation actually based on that. So Yahoo launched the program, what,
2012, 13? Yeah. Yeah. 2019, I found an RCE on the root main domain. So don't give up just because it's
like, oh, this shit is so hard and whatever. In 2019? 19. Yeah. Wow, dude.
Yeah. So there you go. That's, that is many, many years later, you know, people, people fuss
about this sort of thing all the time. Like, ah, you know, this program's been around for three years.
Like I got this private program invited, it's three years old. What was me? Many years later,
seven, eight years later. Yeah, but if you think like that, just go to any, any company or tutor,
your job or something that has like, put their stuff as open source. Look at the chain slope.
And scroll back to whatever, look how many changes there are. Like, of course, there will be.
Yeah. I'm going to send you, I'm going to send you something after this as well.
There's this, there's this host right now that I'm working on or that I've been working on and
Noggle finally convinced me to give it up, I guess. But there's the version number says that it has
patched this severe vulnerability that's at that, at that specific version, right? If you see the
version number in the HTTP response, it says, you know, version whatever. And it, the vulnerability
is patched at that, at that version. But if you go into the GitHub history and you click the patch
right before that, before they fix the vulnerability, the commit right before that, it's a, it's a change to
the readme for this. And it changes a uppercase H to a, or a lowercase H to an uppercase H. And I hit
that readme file and it's still a lowercase H, which means I know that they haven't actually patched
that specific vulnerability yet. Even though the version number aligns with the patched version.
And so I've been trying to build out this exploit. I had to rewrite it because of a HTTP, HTTPS problem.
And something isn't something isn't, the attack complexity might be too much in this scenario
because it there's some mitigating factors, but I might pass it to you anyway and see if I can nerd
snipe you and get you to pop it. Cause it'd be a 15 K bug if we could.
Yeah, man. But you know, that sort of thing, looking at the change log, looking at the git commit
history for open source software is super duper important.
Oh, one more tip.
Yeah.
If the program your, your, your targeting has like an SDK.
Mm. Oh my gosh.
In your automation, pull git updates from the SDK. And then you get a feed of like,
here's something changed. And then you don't be crawling, you don't be scraping. They will just tell
me this change. That's okay.
Yeah, dude. And the SDK is a very underestimated attack surface as well for a lot of companies as
well. That's one thing that I didn't look at for years until freaking Ryotak, the guy that won Vegas
two years back, like just started, cause this whole thing is like source code review. He's just like
literally a source code monster. And he just, you know, just he'll open up a page, right? This is,
this is how, you know, you're dealing with someone who's like a savant, right? Like he opens up a page
and then he'll read the JavaScript from top to bottom, like not, not jump around, not, not trace
the functions. He'll read it from top to bottom and then tell you what's happening with it. And I'm like,
what? Like, what, what is, what are you, how, you know, what are you doing? Um, and he just destroys
any SDK that he, he works on, you know, on these programs because it's open source stuff
and he loves open source stuff. So really amazing to see him work on that really inspiring for me
to go after SDK related, um, volumes. And then I found a bunch after that, which is really exciting.
Um, so yeah, definitely, definitely a great tip there as far as attack surface and as far as recon goes.
Yeah. But also like another tip, I guess, is that modern development, or if they have an SDK or
something of the source, it usually deals with like, is it called test driven development? I don't know.
But that has a bunch of tests and you, and a lot of times those have like security related tests
because they use the end of the bug. Yeah.
So that can be like a really good tip. They're like, oh, if you can just bypass one of these tests,
you've got a free bug. So.
Wow. That's like, that's interesting.
They've given you a tip on marketing.
Yeah. They, they sort of say, okay, hey, this is what we've, this is how we've designed it
to work, you know, and then you can look at, at the holes from that perspective and you know
what not to try. That's, that, that is helpful. Man, you know, Matthias, you have probably done
one of the best jobs of, of anyone on the podcast that we've had on of actually giving actionable,
hands-on advice and tips to people. I have it in my notes right now. I'm going to have some of the
viewers play a drinking game of how many times Matthias says, here's a tip during this episode.
People are going to be like wasted as heck after that. That's great.
But it's like, I listened to the podcast too.
Yeah.
I want to contribute.
That's great, man. I appreciate that. So we're, we're, we're getting to the point where it gets way
too long. But I do want to, I want to have a conversation real quick about GraphQL. I think we'll
skip Docker escape, which is the other thing that we were going to talk about, even though that would
be really, really interesting. GraphQL stuff. Talk to me about GraphQL stuff. What kind of stuff have
you been popping with that recently? And what kind of stuff are you finding interesting?
So I had this notion of, or idea of GraphQL just being like, it's the same thing to test like,
oh, by the way, background. I started, I just started learning like more about GraphQL,
but my previous video of it was like, it's the same thing as the REST API. And if introspection
is on, you get the documentation of the REST data. Basically you get a bunch of input arguments,
that you can like the payloads in them and such. That's for traditional learning. But it turns out
there's a lot more than that because you have a bunch of the,
not fields, what do you call them? Not more. Attributes?
Yeah, a bunch of them. What are you?
Whatever semantics. You have a bunch of operations, let's say. They can be three types. They can be a
query, mutation, or a subscription. Yeah. And the subscription ones are so interesting.
Yeah. I want to pick your brain about that actually, but go, continue.
Yeah. And there's a bunch of different query names, for example. But those names can return
an object that has a subquery in it. And this, I didn't know.
Yep.
So it's like a really fun game of like, okay, I'm getting back this. It has a few contacts. And in
the context field, it actually has a user contact type. And that one has a user. And now I can get the
users. Can I map all of these different types? How can I follow this sort of train of data to the
actual data type that I want to get access to? Exactly. So that's something I didn't know.
Yeah. That's freaking amazing, man. I love embedding subqueries like that and trying to map
it out. And when it has introspection enabled, it's so much easier because you can put it through stuff
like, you know, what is it? GraphQL. I forget what it's called, but you can paste the schema in
there. I've got it in my bookmark somewhere. And it will actually create like a graphical representation
of it. And you can say, okay, this type's linked to this type's linked to this type,
links to this type. And actually I've had it before where they'll actually link like password reset
tokens and like literal password hashes. If you chain it, you know, to a point and then you ask for
that specific field, which is like nuts to me that they would, that they would just expose their whole
database like that. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's a, it's a lot more complex than I thought it would be.
So I'm more familiar with the query and the mutation thing. Talk to me about the last one.
Subscribe. Is it? Subscriptions? Yeah. Subscriptions. Subscriptions are like,
how should you call it? Asynchronous queries or mutations. Okay.
So you create a subscription and then you have either a web socket or a multi-part mixed request.
We didn't talk about like XSS challenge, but they use this. And then you just have like an open
socket. And whenever something is answered or put into that subscription, whatever you ask for,
you'll get data back. Wow. That's, that is, uh, that is very, very interesting. I did not know
that, that, that it was using that multi-part thing that you had in your, in your child. I didn't solve
your heart challenge, but that was, that was, I don't think it's like, or I'm not sure if it's
graph field standard, but like Apollo, you have to look. Yeah. Yeah. That's the one, which is like
like almost, or like an all-around use. Yeah. No, that's a lot. And I, yeah, we meant,
I meant to kind of try to talk through actually that XSS challenge and it kind of got lost in the
whole, um, content, content type, uh, description, but, or the, um, sorry, char set description or
a conversation we had, but I'll link it, link it below the writeup that you have, uh, to this,
to this XSS challenge. You did a great job of actually writing up something at the end that explains
all of the different techniques that you can use to, to do it. And there's one, um,
the multi-part mix that you mentioned. I was on that trail by the way, when I was trying to exploit
it, but I just didn't have the time to get all the way through it. Um, very, very cool piece of
functionality that essentially allows, if I understood it correctly, it allows them to almost sort of keep
an, it's almost like web sockets, but for HTTP. And you can kind of like continue to stream data
over time that have individual content documents within one long streamed HTTP response. Is that
right? That's exactly right. Yeah. Wow. What an interesting piece of functionality there. And
I have to imagine that the, the impact of that is substantial in the context of things like, uh,
HTTP request smuggling and stuff like that too. So definitely some room for some cool research there
for anybody who is into request smuggling and sort of server confusion, confusing servers.
Yeah. That's like, if it's like one way you can do something with a response header injection,
for example, or something like that for sure. Oh yeah. Yeah. Cause then, huh. If you could
redefine the content type, I wonder, uh, but you have to control the content type header the first time
anyway, to get it multi-part mixed because there's a lot of times where like you're injecting after
the content type definition and that sort of thing, and you can't override it. That's
huh. Interesting. I gotta do, I gotta do some more research into that, man. There's there.
My notepad is full. Yeah. You know, I, I have my to-do list today and, and it's like, you know,
record podcasts with Matias and, and, you know, a couple other things. I was getting ready to check this
one off the list, but when I check it off, I've got to add like seven additional items of like,
go research this and, and document it and put it in thing. So thank you very much for that, Matias.
Appreciate that, man. Um, no, seriously though, it's been a great episode and, um, thank you so much for
sharing all your knowledge about all these different areas. And, um, I, I hereby give you permission
in the future to invite yourself back onto the pod whenever you have something interesting that in
your technical context window, so you can get it off your chest and give it to the world. And, uh,
and that we can all benefit from that, including your own memory, having had to put it into words.
So that'll be helpful for everyone involved. I think. Awesome, man. Of course. Have a good one, man.